[Musique]
les visages charmant qui sont ceux de
l'enfance ne saurait plus aujourd'hui
faire illusion
depuis que se sont développés les
techniques de la psychanalyse fondée sur
les théories de sigmund freud
les psychologues sont habiles à
découvrir au détour d'un dessin le
contenu complexe du la main fantine
révolte contre l'école et l'autorité
paternelle par exemple révélé par
l'inversion volontaire des led
l'origine de bien des comportements
étranges apparaît ainsi en clair
inquiétudes d'aller de l'avant
sensation d'être abandonnés crainte
inconsciente d'une hypothétique menace
[Musique]
quant au sentiment d'agressivité il
s'exprime à travers tout un monde peuplé
d'armes à feu que les parents se console
donc ils ne sont plus en ressources même
en face des cas les plus désespérés
nhem en face de ce garnement en
apparence le plus affreux qu'on puisse
imaginer
[Musique]
celui ci qui ne respectent rien que ses
camarades craignent et que ses maîtres
finisseuse aussi par redouté et pour
cause véritable démon terreur de la
classe abonné aux panoplie de cowboy
c'est évidemment le jeune fauve type que
des parents trop faibles ont renoncé à
dompter
[Musique]
celui dont le carnet de notes
particulièrement éloquent créeraient une
atmosphère de deuil il limité s'il
n'avait depuis longtemps su renverser la
situation en y glissant par exemple en
prévision de la fête des mères un billet
de la loterie nationale en toute
innocence bien sûr le brave petit
[Musique]